what's going on everyone i want to make
a quick video for you guys about the
only three things to say
when closing or selling and the reason
this came up was uh recently i was on
uh i was coaching our sales team uh on
just just going over game tape footage
which is like hey how's you know let's
let's watch the sale from yesterday
you know what we could what was done
well what was great what was bad what
could have been improved etc
and one of the the habits that some of
our team gets in because
our our sales team is really
knowledgeable we call them business
consultants because they really are
i mean they really are business
consultants you know what i mean and
that's why sometimes it's harder to find
good sales people because they have to
have um
a really high level of understanding if
you're going to like the higher the
level of the business that you're going
to be selling the higher level of
expertise the person talking them must
have
if they have no context that's why like
low level transactional sales like if
you're doing b2c
you know supplement sales over the phone
you really don't need to have an
exquisitely you know knowledgeable uh
a rep it's more about a very
transactional process that's going to be
very highly scripted minimum variability
right whereas if you're talking about a
complex business deal
right um then you need to have a very
good understanding of their business
where there's potential opportunities et
cetera right
and so sometimes it can be difficult
because you may want to switch
and this is especially true when it's uh
if you're the owner of the business or
you're
you know integrally involved in just a
couple of sales people you may get into
the mode of trying to teach which is one
of the biggest
um a mistakes but b um
one of the biggest hard things to not do
there's some good words um as a
salesperson right because if you're
trying to close a deal you want to
educate the person but the reality is
that's not they're not going to listen
to you until they buy and so there's no
actual point in quote teaching
but you do want to coach and that's
something that i was talking about with
my team
yesterday is the difference between
teaching and coaching and so
fundamentally there's only three types
of statements that should come out of
your mouth when you are selling
number one and most likely to be coming
out is questions
all right so if you don't know what
types of questions
um like for us i i prefer
question-based frameworks for more
complex sales um and the reason for that
is these are the types of questions that
we would need to know the answer to in
order to work with someone
it's also the only way you can get
someone to change their beliefs about
something
because ultimately the person especially
the more complex the higher level the
sale
the the more the person has to come to
the conclusion on their own that they
should work with you and less
feel forced or suggested hopefully that
makes sense
and so we should ask leading questions
that lead them to the conclusion
that they should work with you can solve
their problems the second
uh type of thing is a restatement which
means uh
after they say something you say it back
to them
which means that you understand and you
are listening all right
so it's like so what i'm hearing is this
is the primary issue that you've been
trying to solve this is what you've done
so far
and this is why it hasn't worked does
that sound about right so that would be
an example of restatement
notice none of these things
are our declarative statements of fact
i'm not teaching them anything
all right which is the same reason that
people get in trouble when they do
presentations to try and pitch
they try and teach the thing is is
person has to have their beliefs broken
in order to take action
and you're not providing value in a real
way because the reality is they're not
going to execute on anything you teach
them
they will only execute if they have
their beliefs broken and believe you can
help them and then that they can trust
what you are saying
this is like this was so hard for me to
learn because in the very beginning when
i started gym lunch i just wanted to go
in and get on the phone and jim's oh no
no
your pricing is all wrong you got to do
this you got to do this guy do this and
they were just like
take lots of notes and then end up
getting off the call not buying and then
be like well uh i don't even know who
this guy is i'm just going to ignore it
and so i didn't actually help them i
thought i was helping them
but i was not actually helping them and
i actually heard this from talking more
a good friend of mine
he said everyone gets benefits from
breaking beliefs only 10 of people get
benefits from tactics
and so you actually are providing more
value on the call
by questioning their beliefs because
you're actually servicing a hundred
percent
of the people providing value compared
to trying to give tactical advice
that only one out of ten people may or
may not use and likely the people who
will use it are not buying from you
so either way you're you're not
benefiting your business and you're also
not benefiting there's that was a huge
thing that i had to
break with my own beliefs and so then
you might be wondering well if i'm only
asking questions and restating things
how do i close the deal
great great question glad you asked all
right
and so what i like are short stories
and so the reason we do this is that
so we'd ask a question ask a serious
question hey why are you here
what are you struggling with where you
at right now where you trying to go what
have you tried so far how's that working
for you
um why is this important does it matter
like within the bigger context of
of your life and what you're trying to
do okay great this is what i'm hearing i
think this is why
uh you haven't been successful would you
agree with that does that make sense
fantastic do you want to hear how our
program works
right so at that point you'd enter quote
the pitch right which is where you're
gonna explain how the services work
this is where most guys and gals will
just blab
right they'll just talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and try and teach
and about how they have this secret
system in the
and really uh i think russell brunson
calls it technobabble it's like
you talk about your periodization you
talk about your plan or you talk about
your programs you're talking about the
softwares or whatever
right the route is they don't care and
so all we have to do
realistically is tell a story that
illustrates
what they're going to experience as a
result all right and so
um if i were trying to sell uh
you know i'll just use gym launch as a
simple example so if i'm like listen
fundamentally until you learn how to
market your business
you're never going to be free and
earlier you said that the goal when we
asked for context is that you want to
you want to be free you want this
business to be able to run on its own
um does that sound about right yes okay
cool well then
then do you see a world in which you're
going to be able to
outsource the most important part of
your business which is acquisition
lead generation lead nursery and sales
do you feel like there's a world where
you can just
offload that responsibility and then
somehow have a reliable business because
what if that business goes out of
business
which is likely happens all the time
then what right you're never actually
going to be free until you learn this
which means you have to confront this
either today tomorrow or 10 years from
now but you're going to have to do it
does that sound fair does that make
sense
right and so here what i'm doing is i'm
trying to i'm telling i'm telling a
story to break a belief
i'm not saying let me show you how we're
going to teach you
how to market instead i'm saying we have
to at least come to an agreement that
you need to learn this skill
does that sound fair yes and then the
next kind of mini story and if i if they
didn't understand it then it would be
like well this is the difference between
giving a fish
and teaching a man to fish right now you
need to learn how to fish for yourself
right in order for this business to be
sustainable for you right right
and so these are little analogies that
you've already pre-packaged
if i was selling weight loss i would say
something like
all right well fundamentally you know
fitness nutrition accountability you
need these three things fitness-wise
you're gonna have to come and work out
here we agree that you need to work out
right
right why haven't you been working out
so far i don't know how
fair enough is it also because you're
not motivated to do it yes what if you
actually what do you what something that
you like doing
well i like doing i like watching tv
cool what if
what if working out was something that
you could look forward to as much as or
more than watching tv
if you liked working out more than
watching television which one would you
think you would do
why probably work out right so our goal
is not to get you to work out but learn
to like
working out more than watching
television if we can accomplish that
then we're going to solve this problem
for good does that make sense
yes notice i told them they're going to
have to work out
i did not talk about the the the new the
exercise selection we're going to do the
programming how we're going to ramp up
their volume
their undulating periodization the fancy
exercise like none of that stuff we
talked about
because it doesn't matter we have to
just come to an agreement that this is
what we're going to be doing to solve
the problem
does that make sense yes fantastic when
we move forward
right and so you'll have these
pre-packaged ideas and other examples if
i if i had somebody who wasn't
i'm giving you these examples to
hopefully drive the point home if
someone said uh you know
you're gonna have to change the way you
eat for example and i'd say okay well
you've probably tried stuff in the past
right i'm not gonna talk to him with a
[ __ ] meal plan
right it doesn't matter right it does
matter but not in this conversation it
does not matter
fundamentally you're going to change the
way you eat because what you got
like why you are here is because of
something you are currently doing does
that sound fair
right okay cool so again with this
example i'd be like well do you like
cake do you like cookies
yes okay so then the key do you think
you could not eat cookies for this your
life
do you think you cannot eat cake or not
eat ice cream thrust your life do you
think that's reasonable
no i don't think that's reasonable cool
so then we have to figure out a way for
you to eat the things that you enjoy
and still lose weight and do it in a way
so that you look forward to it because
at the end of the day if you like the
food
more than you're currently eating you
will stick with it does that sound fair
yes because do you think that you can
sustainably give yourself willpower for
the rest of your life
no okay well then can we agree that all
we have to do is just simply
figure out the foods that you will like
and that's an iterative process for us
and we'll walk through it but the end
goal is that you will like this more
than you're currently eating
and as a result of that will stick with
it which means that over the long haul
you'll get to where you want to go
does that sound fair yes notice again
this is an explanation this is a this is
a mini story this is an analogy
that we'll use and you should have
multiple of these so you can drive the
point home if you feel like the prospect
does not understand what you are saying
right and so this is where we are
we are coaching based on beliefs we are
not
explaining or tacticalizing or
technobabbling about our program
because fundamentally it does not matter
they don't care nor will they listen
they're not even paying whenever you
have a monotone you can see it in
gong recordings if you don't if you
don't record this you can see talk time
you can see
where engagement goes down and in
invariably it's when a
salesman gets to this part of the pitch
and then they talk for five minutes
straight
no one cares i'm sure like i'm sure that
when you've been if you've ever been
sold something
you feel like the person isn't listening
to you right
and so what i can say is the best way
to sell is to have the person feel like
you understand them
and the best way for someone to feel
understood is for you to actually give a
[ __ ]
if you actually give a [ __ ] you will
know what questions to ask in what order
because those are the questions that you
would naturally ask
the reason scripts were even invented is
to mimic or structure
a conversation between somebody who
cares and someone that they can help
that is what a sale is is we're we're
breaking their beliefs we're coaching
them to the conclusion that they have
not been able to make up for this point
which is that they need to work with us
in order to solve their problem and
we should be okay with the fact that i
would like to provide value to this
person so that i can break their beliefs
around this whether they work with me or
not
this is still the type of solution that
they're going to need and if you can
approach it like that you stop having
your ego tied up in your closing
percentages in your numbers
and instead you start helping people on
the phone and by extension you will sell
more deals
all right and it's not by proving your
expertise
and and ego ego babbling about how smart
you are
right instead it's asking them questions
making sure they understand that you're
that you're tracking what they're saying
asking more leading questions restating
what they said and then when they ask
you about how they could potentially
work for you then and only then
you give them the stories to explain how
it works
that's the deal and one of the big rules
that i was hitting on with our sales
team
yesterday is you do not pitch the
program
until you believe the person will say
yes
lawyers do not ask questions they do not
already already know the answers to
no guy most guys don't propose to
someone without already know the
person's gonna say yes the the take rate
on proposals is very high
right let's be real most you know girls
say yes to a proposal
most right i'm not saying all but most
do and sales should be the same way
if you feel like you don't think you're
going to close this person
do not pitch them continue to stay in
this circle
where you are asking questions and
reinstating and clarifying
until you can eventually find that that
piece that thread
that was unexposed that you need to pull
to then get them to say that aha
that's the issue right and so from this
the three things that you should be
using when you're closing is you should
be asking questions you should be
restating what they said
and then once you've exhausted these
pieces where it becomes obvious that
they you need to move on the sale
only at that point they'll say well how
do i how do i work with you how does the
program work
they should be asking you or you can at
the very least say would you like to
know the programmers i think it might be
a good fit for you
at that point they can give you
permission to say yes
now if someone says yeah hey hey tell me
how the program works it's like no i
don't think we're ready for that right
now
i need to understand more about your
business otherwise it's not gonna it's
not gonna make any sense
i don't have enough context right and
again when you do that you can retake
the frame in the conversation if
someone's commanding you around you're
not going to close the deal
right and so a lot of times usually
within the first five to 10 minutes you
can tell
whether you're not going to close the
deal most people most experienced sales
people know
by how the first five to ten minutes go
whether this person's
really even five minutes um you can tell
whether you're gonna be able to close
this person or not
and if you don't feel like you're gonna
be able to close this person it means
you need a state shift you need to
shift the frame and the only way to do
that is to ask questions
that are challenging one of the things i
have my team say is closers ask hard
questions
right is ask questions that are going to
challenge their current paradigm
if they're in a current paradigm that
they're getting on the phone because
they want to prove to themselves that
nothing's going to work for them
then you need to say it sounds like it
sounds like you're out a lot
sounds like your business is kind of
there's no way for you to succeed
does that sound about right and then
they're gonna sell you on why you're
wrong but by selling you and why they're
wrong they're taking a contrarian stance
which then
proves to you that there is a way rather
than saying no i think you can be
successful they're like no i can't be
successful right
and so understanding that before you get
into your pitch the person must already
be sold on working with you
is one of the biggest things i can give
you right now so if your script has too
many paragraphs and too much explanation
and all of that stuff
then it's off it just needs to be
questions and restating for
clarification that you are hearing what
they're saying
and asking the next natural question
that will lead logically to them working
with you and asking the question at the
end which is well how do i do this that
sounds amazing that's exactly what i
want like how do i move forward with the
details etc
and then at that point you say cool this
is how it works ready to rock and roll
all right
fair enough hope that makes sense keep
being awesome lots of love and
i'll see you guys on flip side bye